vraiment un coup de feu la remontée qui
s'est mis dans cette fumée et des
flammes monter au dessus des sapins des
arbres calcinés un sol jonché de cendres
c'était le 19 juillet dernier aux
alentours de 15h30 un incendie s'est
déclaré au niveau du massif forestier de
rochefort en yvelines 5 hectares sont
partis en fumée c'était le second feu
depuis le début de l'année le 21 avril
dernier huit hectares de végétation
avaient déjà brûlé quand j'ai appris le
deuxième feu j'ai dit encore
effectivement être encore une deuxième
fois touché sur la commune et dans cette
belle forêt encore sûr à part un feu
s'était c'est vrai que c'est on
désespère un petit peu au total 74
pompiers des yvelines mais aussi des
sols ou d'eure-et-loir s'étaient rendus
sur les lieux pour maîtriser le feu un
effort que le maire a salué les regards
sont maintenant tournés vers le futur ce
qui on veut me l'espoir c'est de voir la
tâche verbe qui a là bas on voit que
même si la prophétie le parti nazi
foresti les flammes étaient beaucoup
plus forte beaucoup plus haute que au
mois d'avril quand on voit comme ça
toute cette brouille air qui a disparu
je ne sais pas quand même temps il
faudra pour se recomposer
les boulots en l'air d'être aussi bien
touché je pense qu'il y aura un verdict
ça sera le printemps on verra ce qui
arrivera à renaître je sais que le
département où le n est fait plus dans
un premier temps justement de regarder
par une renaturation naturel pour voir
ce qui se passe avant de réfléchir à je
dirais haras planter des espèces sur le
territoire l'occasion également de
rappeler les bonnes pratiques par ces
temps sec
le moindre la moindre étincelle le
moindre je dirais peut-être même morceau
de verre oublier à un certain endroit
peut faire loupe et déclencher un
incendie je parle même pas des mégots de
cigarette qu'on arrive à trouver ici
même sur les chemins le 19 juillet les
pompiers sont intervenus sur 19 feux de
forêts et de broussailles dans les
yvelines un record sur le département